اهلا بكم من جديد فيروس قديم جديد عمره
اكثر من خمسه عقود وصفته الصحه العالميه
بالمرض الفتاك هذا الفيروس ليس له علاج
ويقتل نحو 90% من المصابين به مما دفع
منظمه الصحه العالميه الى دق ناقوس الخطر
قبل ان يتحول الى جائحه عالميه بعد ان
تفشى في دولتين افريقيا هما غينيا
وتنزانيا المنظمه الامميه عقد اجتماعا
عاجلا بشان مار بورد وجمعت خبراء الصحه من
جميع انحاء العالم لمناقشه سبل تطوير
اللقاحات او علاجات قبل ان يعود العالم
لمشهد كورونا المرعب اما اعراض الفيروس
فهي شبيهه باعراض الانفلونزا لكنها قاتله
بعد ايام فقط من الاصابه به وينتمي الى
عائله فايروس ايبولا الخطير
مشاهدينا لا ينتقل عبر الهواء وينتشر
بسرعه من خلال الاتصال المباشر بين البشر
خاصه المرتبطين بالسوائل مثل الدم او
اللعاب ويمكن حتى لجثث المصابين ان تبقى
معديه عند الدفن خبراء الصحه يوضحون ان
الوقايه بشكل عام من الحمى النزفيه
المرتبطه بالفيروسات مثل
قد تكون امرا صعبا ويجب استخدامه وسائل
الحمايه مثل ارتداء القفازات والاقنعه
وطرد الحشرات والقوارض هذا الامر دفع
بالدول العربيه مثل السعوديه والامارات
والكويت وعمان بتوصيه مواطنيها بتاجيل
السفر في الوقت الحالي الى كل من تنزانيا
وغينيا الاستوائيه
[موسيقى]